بينما يدفع أوروبا إلى شفا
الحرب ، اتهم المسؤولون الأمريكيون العقيد السابق في الكرملين في الكرملين
باختلاق
الذرائع لغزو أوكرانيا ،
ويقول محللون لفلاديمير بوتين إن أوكرانيا
شخصية في وقت مبكر من رئاسته ، أخبر
أمته اقتبس زوال
الاتحاد السوفياتي  كانت أعظم
كارثة جيوسياسية في القرن
وكانت هناك جمهورية سوفيتية واحدة
ندم على خسارتها بشكل خاص بالنسبة
له.أوكرانيا هي جوهرة التاج التي فقدت ،
أوكرانيا
دولة شقيقة كتب مقالًا كاملاً
يدور في الأساس نوعًا من الحكاية التاريخية الزائفة
حول سبب أوكرانيا  لا ينبغي حقًا أن
تكون منفصلة عن روسيا الأم في هذا
المقال في الصيف الماضي ، كتب بوتين أن
الروس والأوكرانيين هم شعب
واحد ككل وأن أوكرانيا الحديثة
تشكلت لجزء كبير على
أراضي روسيا التاريخية يقول الخبراء أن
بوتين كان دائمًا يرى أن
على الدول الواقعة على أطراف
روسيا أن تكون موالية لروسيا ويرى أن
الحكومة الأوكرانية الصديقة للغرب
هي ثروة.  إلى هذا المثل الأعلى لكنهم يقولون أيضًا إن
الرجل الذي ولد ونشأ في ما يُعرف الآن باسم
سانت بطرسبرغ مقعد القياصرة
لديه إرثه الخاص في الاعتبار عندما يتعلق
الأمر بما يحدث في أوكرانيا ، فهو يريد
أن يكون إرثه مثل قياصرة العظماء.
الماضي أو رؤساء الاتحاد السوفياتي
الذي ترك روسيا كقوة عظمى
يُخشى احترامها وتدريبها على التعامل
بجدية في العالم ، يقول المحللون إن
بوتين قد انزعج مما كان
يعتبره إدارات أمريكية سابقة تتعامل مع
روسيا كقوة أقل ، وهذا
استعراض له  إن العضلات مع أوكرانيا هي وسيلة
للحفاظ على أهمية بلاده ، فهو يريد
أن يأتي الناس إلى روسيا لحل
مشاكل العالم ، لأنهم يمثلون تهديدًا
للآخرين ، وهذا أفضل من
عدم الاحترام أو التجاهل ، لكن
مراقبي الكرملين يقولون إن الرجل الذي يُنظر إليه على أنه
الاستراتيجي النهائي ربما يكون قد بالغ في تقديره.
يده هذه المرة ، قد تكون
حرب حسابات خاطئة مريعة
كما تعلم أنها تؤدي إلى
عواقب غير متوقعة ، فإن العواقب
الاقتصادية للغزو ستكون هائلة في الوقت
الراهن.  يقول المحللون إن الولايات المتحدة
بقوة مثل فلاديمير بوتين
ستضر الحرب الدموية الطويلة في
أوكرانيا بإرثه
وقد تبدأ في تهديد سيطرته على السلطة
كما يشير أحد الخبراء إلى
خسائر كبيرة من الحرب في أفغانستان
ساهمت في تفكك
السوفيت.  اتحاد